probiotics have become commonplace in
many products we consume like yogurt
certain drinks and supplements because
they are thought to have numerous health
benefits but to understand how exactly
these products work we first need to
understand the concept of a microbiome
a microbiome is a community of
microorganisms such as bacteria fungi
and even viruses that inhabit a specific
environment communicate with each other
share resources and exhibit a particular
Collective action based on their
surroundings
many of these communities of
microorganisms exist within other
organisms such as humans but they can
also exist in the world around us
let's start with the humans first
there are multiple microbiomes within
the human body including on the skin in
the gastrointestinal tract lungs and
even the belly button
healthy microbiomes are critical because
each of these collections of microbes
ensures our body functions normally
for example the bacteria in the skin
microbiome use a process called Quorum
sensing to communicate with each other
and form a biofilm that helps defend us
from harmful infections and other skin
conditions
the most well-known microbiome in the
human body however is the community of
microbes that live in our digestive
tracts the gut microbiome
here the microbes primarily help us
break down the food that we eat into
nutrients that can be absorbed by our
body
more recently scientists have discovered
that the gut microbiome also plays
critical roles from a very young age
like helping to develop the immune
system
if any of these communities are
disrupted or become unbalanced it can
have significant Health consequences
which we see with antibiotics while
these medicines killed the bad bacteria
that cause infections they can kill the
good bacteria too
in the gut this can lead to abdominal
pain fatigue and disruption of blood
sugar regulation
probiotics which are a collection of the
good bacteria can help restore some of
the gut microbiome that is lost due to
antibiotic treatment disease or other
factors
while microbiomes in the body are the
most well known because of their direct
impact on our health
microbiomes outside of the body are just
as important for example there is a
unique microbiome that exists around
deep sea hydrothermal vents areas of the
seafloor that spew scalding water and
chemicals that would be toxic to most
living organisms
this community of microbes is able to
convert many of these toxic chemicals
into organic materials that can be used
by other organisms keeping the ecosystem
around these vents healthy
so the next time you see probiotics or
your deep sea diving don't forget about
the microbiomes that are playing a huge
role in not only your health but also
that of the environment around you